let's get into uh some more hard
politics though so you're running for
office robbie
where are you running for office and for
what office are you running tennessee in
the fifth congressional district this
almost looks like a story that might be
in my race
so uh you
the big story around you is that uh
you're endorsed by trump right no no no
no he announced the other he endorsed
the other one yeah and people got very
angry about it yeah wrong wrong very
wrong you know love the guy but um i
think he actually did not realize that
this was the race i was in when he made
an endorsement the big story was that it
appears the it's the republicans right
they're trying to stop you from being
able to run for office so they're trying
to stop morrigan and initially we're
trying to stop me too but um they didn't
realize how long i had lived in the
state so this bill that they passed
actually doesn't apply to me because
i've been a resident of tennessee over
three years
by the time of the election which is
what the amended law is so let's break
this down for us like you're running for
office how does it happen that they're
trying to block you from being able to
run for office well basically and you're
like you're like a trump supporter like
a populist yeah well i think that's
that's the problem right is that i don't
answer to them i have no favors that i
owe anybody and that's the most
dangerous thing in politics is somebody
running who doesn't owe anybody favors
um you know so there's a lot of sort of
people who've been there for a long time
in the political establishment who are
very threatened by this guy showing up
out of nowhere crushing it in polls
having hundreds to thousands of people
at every event
and they're just like what the heck is
going on here we may have a problem on
our hands because if he's able to do
that then he could turn those people out
in races that we're in you know and i
think that's where the mental calculus
goes but then you know morgan came out
too and trump endorsed her and i think
they kind of felt a similar way with her
but a little different it wasn't so much
the populist fear but more so the fear
of like hey you're not from here you
know this this should be from for
somebody from here you know
and i think it's a little wrong headed
you know i understand the instinct some
of them have because you want somebody
to represent the district who actually
has the state's interests in mind and
who understands the people and i agree
with that but when you look at what they
did here it's just the same sort of
disgusting you know sneaky politics that
people hate where you know you play by
the rules and if you're winning then we
change the rules it's like wall street
bets you know like if you're winning
suddenly it's like no no the rules need
to change and now you need to win by
these rules and what they changed is you
were saying before that they have a law
that says you have lived in the state
for three years three years until
election day and so for the people who
don't know the difference between the
races and stuff because it is a little
confusing in like house rep races you
can have those qualifications because
the state it's a state office the state
gets to set the qualifications for
federal office though for u.s congress
which is what i'm running for or for
senate um on the senate side or house
side of congress
you cannot do that as a state you know
at least constitutionally it's there's a
qualifications clause it's very clear
you have to be 25 years old and um you
know there's nothing about you needing
to be a resident of the state for x
amount of years you just need to be a us
citizen
um and so that's where i think they got
it wrong with this i do think it's a
matter of does somebody want to
challenge it in court or not and i don't
know if they'll want to i don't need to
because it doesn't affect me but um i
think some people have a mindset where
they say states should get to decide
this sort of thing and if they have that
mindset maybe they walk away from the
race you know and say all right i'll try
to do something else but you know if
they were doing it to me and it did
affect me i would fight like hell i i do
see the purpose of a bill you don't want
some random person you know maybe
somebody who was i don't know a governor
of uh what massachusetts or something or
or someone or like a spokesperson for
some
you know like a former governor like
flying to another state and then running
for senate or something like that you
know what i mean like he's like you
don't live here you don't really
represent us but i suppose the the the
response i typically get from people
typically get is people can vote for
whoever they want exactly well this is
what my argument is and it's kind of
counter-intuitive because you know i'm
almost shooting myself in the foot i
maybe shouldn't say this but even though
it doesn't affect me
i have a principal problem with this
like just if i'm being consistent with
my values my morals
i think this is wrong if we care about
election integrity we should care about
people deciding elections i don't want
to boot somebody from a race against me
and beat them by proxy because they got
kicked out i want to beat them on
election day with people
voting for me more often than they vote
for them you know and that's how it
should be in our elections you should be
able to count on that that you're going
to be able to get the real choices but
there's so much dirty dirty there is
it's a dirty dirty business and and
that's i talked about this with a couple
members actually this week and there's
no business like this where you're
expected to stab your friends in the
back on a constant basis
did
why would you want to be
in in congress well so for me
it's one of those things where i'm
looking at it from a state of not what
is good for me but a state of function
of what's good for my kids and i
realized that if we continue this same
pattern of having these career
politicians same lawyers from same
schools you know same sort of sets of
values and we keep sending them there
we're living the definition of insanity
this is just the same thing over and
over again and have we not learned the
lesson so i said you know what i have
nothing to lose we're going to go try
and we're going to run a campaign that
is everything that i believe in and i'm
not going to owe anybody anything and
it's sort of like
for me i look back and i think back to
when i first got super engaged in
politics and it was ron paul
and i say what would have happened to
our country had ron paul become
president i'm just imagining everyone
holding hands and singing under a
rainbow everyone's pockets bursting with
cash and guns gold
guns and gold
guns and gold probably a crypto economy
right now
no we'd be a gold there would be a
golden bag yep yeah no no fed no fed the
fed would have been destroyed you know i
mean no but seriously if you think he's
so wealthy in advance ron paul would be
a cyborg by now he would he'd be a
cyborg he'd be you know he would have
bought cnn and turned it into something
wonderful
be like they would have gained channels
to run a third time but he would have
refused to yeah he would have had to
have refused yes i have to be honest
though i obviously wouldn't be a utopia
but i do think it would be a little bit
similar to donald trump oh yeah no i
think so absolutely and the media would
have treated him the way they treated
trump
crazy old yeah he's crazy he's totally
unhinged you know but the people would
have loved him you know and what was
really impressive about ron paul was
his connection with young people and
people who did not traditionally fit
into the republican mold you know of
what the media wanted you to believe a
republican was and i also felt like that
was another important reason for me to
run was i was like you know i'm tired of
people framing us as this
you know
this tiny box and we all have to fit
inside this cleanly and if we don't then
there's there's just something wrong
with it you know because it's almost
like if you met somebody who looked like
me you would have to expect they're
definitely not a republican
and i think that that's something that
needs to change because the funny part
of it is is like i'm more conservative
than your you know average you could
pull anybody out of the legislature and
i'm more conservative than them and they
may look like they'd fit the part but
if you actually got down to policy and
it was me versus that person making
decisions you're going to be much
happier with the decision i make than
the one they make
you remember the ron paul love
revolution yes it was revolution but
then love flipped around yeah love was
flipped around so it's actually the um
i've only done political ads twice in my
life and the first one i ever did was
for the ron paul campaign and it
included that in it um
yes yes
and we need more of that energy you know
maybe not so much the love at this point
but that'll come later you know but we
need the people to
make some decisions here about what they
want
what i've always liked about ron paul is
that uh you know back then like 2008 and
2009 or whatever i was you know more
lefty but i was like i like this guy
because he comes out and he has a bunch
of things i don't agree with and then he
just says
you know but but i'm not going to ever
have the government come and tell you
what to do and i'm like then we're good
yeah i'm like i don't care what you
believe like you believe a bunch of
things i don't agree with you on those
policies
but then your policy is to leave me
alone yes all right win-win that's the
greatest policy you can run with as a
politician is i want to leave you alone
you know it really is i want to leave
you to do what you want to do within
reason obviously we're not going to let
you go and share you know like child
sexual abuse material or something like
that but you know in general you want to
live your life seems to be the democrat
motto these days it does it's that
democrats would like a world like that
you know where they're able to allow
everything but crypto pedos and pedo
adjacent
you know we we've got to get to a point
where the people really are in control
again and that's not going to happen
unless people like me go ahead and take
the leap and say you know what i'll go
do this and i'm definitely not doing it
for 30 years i think honestly those
people who grow up and they're like i
want to be in congress they're they have
mental problems okay if we're being real
with each other they have mental
problems they're sociopaths and total
narcissists think about how many little
girls today turn on the tv and they see
nancy pelosi
and they're like i want to be that
yep they should probably
be locked up
if they think that when they see nancy
pelosi i'm joking of course but um
they're going to be like he's imagine he
wants to arrest kids
they probably will um but no
you know i think that we've got to give
people something to believe in again in
terms of them being able to have the
power again and if the wrong people keep
getting into the positions of power in
this country we're never going to get
there and our kids are going to grow up
in a country that is
incredibly
just inverse from what we want for our
families you know i mean like normal
people want freedom they want they want
to just be able to live a life where you
know their their kids get to go to a
good school they have a decent job they
get to go on a date every once in a
while they get to take a vacation with
their kids once a year like people
aren't asking for much and the
government in turn turns around and
slaps them all the time you know and i
think that
we've got to understand
this is probably a good way to frame it
i was asked recently by seb gorka he
said you know you've been around all
these places in your district what is
the common theme and i could give a
political answer but there's there's no
use in it the real answer is pain
there's something about pain and grief
and trauma
that ignites something different in
people
and the pain i'm seeing from people in
their experiences it's not just about
money it's not just about economic
overturn or gas prices or any of these
things it's about a lifetime in many
cases but decades at the very least of
being lied to
being slapped at every turn by your
government and essentially feeling like
you run through the same cycle over and
over of abuse
and they're tired they're sick of it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there